foreign
a traditional drinking vessel typically
used for beer a Tankard often has a
hinged lid you raise and lower with a
thumb lever
dating back to 15th century England they
were initially made of wood then silver
or pewter the tradition of handcrafting
pewter tankards continues today
this manufacturer makes pewter tankards
in many styles one of which has the
legend of the king's Shilling engraved
on it and a reproduction of a shilling
coin from 1816 encased in the glass
bottom
every step is done by hand beginning
with a sheet of pewter that's just 1 14
of an inch thick using a punch press
they cut it into the shape required to
form the tankard's body
next they place the pewter on a copper
plate that has on it and raised
lettering the story of the king's
shilling
they feed this in between two rollers
that press the lettering into the pewter
a soft metal pewter is composed mostly
of tin along with smaller quantities of
two other metals antimony and copper
next a metalsmith takes over he manually
bends the pewter into the cylindrical
shape of the tankard's body
he brushes on flux a chemical which
helps molten metal flow more easily then
with a soldering tool he fuses the edges
of the body with pure tin solder
traditionally both the pewter and cider
contained lead but today both are lead
free
next the metalsmith slides the cylinder
onto a steel form and hammers the solder
seam flat rendering it virtually
invisible
foreign
Tradesman known as a pewter spinner
slips the body onto a lathe
as the lathe rotates he uses a series of
tools to smooth the surface trim excess
off the top and bottom and turn the top
Edge over to form a lip
next a buffer uses pumice and a cloth
buffing wheel to remove imperfections
and make the Surface silky smooth
meanwhile in the casting department they
heat solid pewter to 465 degrees
Fahrenheit then carefully pour the now
molten metal into a rubber mold
inside are several cavities for
Shillings and large rings after about 30
seconds the pewter solidifies and the
parts can come out
to make the tankard's handle the casters
pour molten pewter into a steel mold
then tilt the mold in all directions to
spread the rapidly setting metal all
along the wall of the cavity
this makes the handle Hollow and
therefore lightweight
they grind the ends on an abrasive belt
so the handle will fit flush against the
tanker body
another worker meanwhile assembles the
tankard's glass base a glass disc a
shilling a ring then a second glass disc
the ring acts as a spacer creating
enough of a gap between the glass discs
to allow the coin to slide around
he applies waterproof glue around the
perimeter to adhere everything together
next he places this Shilling sandwich in
a pewter base and adheres a second ring
to hide the glue
back to the metalsmith now he dabs the
tankard's body onto a pad impregnated
with flux
he then solders together the body and
base
[Music]
once the parts are attached a final
buffing with a soft felt wheel
next the metalsmith dips the handle ends
and flux
and solders them to the body
to avoid scorching the Tankard surface
this time he uses a bismuth and Tin
solder which requires a lower
temperature to melt
the Tankard is now fully constructed
they clean it in a dishwasher
then shine it up first the polisher does
the inside using a rough grid abrasive
compound producing a matte finish
then he polishes the outside using a
finer grit compound this produces a
contrasting mirror finish
in 18th and 19th century England a
volunteer for Army or Naval service
accepted as Shilling as a bonus upon
signing up however volunteers were in
short supply so recruiters are said to
have visited pubs and slip Shillings
into the pewter tankards of inebriated
men
who upon their last sip discovered
they'd been duped into serving
it may well be a myth but it still makes
a darn good story to share over a pint